[Music]
what makes a Titan a Titan well
apparently it's not size as confusing as
it may be it has something to do with
effects a creature has on its
environment something like radiation
After Effects and also their powers
which although is vague can still be
roughly understood in certain contexts
like for example the Titan of Greek
mythology were not all of gigantic
stature of course Kronos swallowed his
children Zeus Poseidon and Hades and
therefore for by influence was bigger
than the average man both the Titans and
gods of Greek myths were known more for
their powers and influence over their
respective domains and environments so
the same with the monsters they have now
classified Titans as creatures with a
unique ability that can alter or
influence the surroundings they are in
with their unique powers that is and
it's it's not just about size so with
this in mind let's take a look at which
monsters in the monsterverse are now
Titans and which are just super species
let's get to it Godzilla is obviously a
Titan and his powers are being the alpha
predator his Atomic nature and the
ability to control other Titans he can
also sense when something is wrong on
earth when looming threats are beginning
to appear like when Gora and mea
Godzilla were about to make their
destructive appearances okay so he is a
Titan what about Kong he has no special
powers or abilities well not yet let GX
give him something and then we can know
for sure what his full potentials are as
of now with the current legendary logic
not ours their logic we should consider
Kong as a big super species a sub Tian
and not a fully fledged Titan but let's
not be crazy we will always put Kong on
the list of one of the alpha
Titans Now Mothra she has the god race
she can disperse weather formations and
affect the atmosphere she also has some
sort of ability to sense disturbances
over the Earth's atmosphere and the
surface an ability she passed on to
Godzilla when she died at the hands of
gidora in kotm so along with these she
also has telepathic abilities and
immortality so yeah she fits the Titan
criteria very well now Rodan he has a
fire volcanic nature and his wings can
create hurricane-like winds that destroy
surface structures and the environment
as such he is classified as a destroyer
Titan Mel d even claims that Rodan is
able to swim in magma to travel meaning
he has dominion over the part of the
earth that isn't solid or water the
mantle beneath the crust gidora his
bioelectric nature allows him to shoot
gravity beams that are powerful enough
to hurt Godzilla incapacity Rodan and
kill Mothra Gora could also conduct
electrical currents making water vapor
heat up to extreme levels and creating
localized storm systems as well as other
worldly Tempest of thunder and yellow
lightning this makes him a Titan an
alien Titan at that now methusa the
grand old methusa has no specific
radiation ability nor does he have any
extraordinary power which by Legend re's
logic he wouldn't be considered a Titan
although he does have the ability to
sleep and blend in with the Rocky and
mountainous terrain often hibernating in
the region for centuries which can
affect the local habitat and Wildlife so
maybe a Titan BY that factor maybe what
about Behemoth this creature is tered by
monar as having a biosis mic nature
meaning he has the ability to influence
the ground and the life forms within his
vicinity and apparently his poop and
radiation can give rise to Forest and
sustain or rejuvenate destroyed ons as
well as bring back old prehistoric
species that have since been lost maybe
seeds that were stuck in his poop then
we have Silla definitely a Titan as it
has liquid nitrogen excretion processes
lowering down the temperatures of the
South Pole revitalizing the polar ice
cap Silla also possesses deadly waterbor
bacteria in her gut that helps her to
consume and digest Titan carcasses that
makes her a scavenger and a restorer of
the natural order now the skull crawlers
or the skull devil these Cranium reptin
species are well just a super species
that dwell beneath the surface of Skull
Island and probably originated from the
hollow Earth the small skull crawler
specimens can be term as just large
meapa while the skull Devil Due to its
size and Hyper predatory nature can be
put in the list of a sub Tian and not a
full-fledged Titan the mutos and Muto
Prime well these are definitely Titans
and check all the necessary boxes they
are huge they have a bio Atomic nature
allowing them to feed on radiation they
can emit EMP pulses which disrupt even
the atomic nature of Godzilla they have
brought mass extinction events in the
past in the earth's past and strangely
the mutos passively produce lifegiving
radiation that exponentially increases
plant growth and other forms of life as
seen in Las Vegas now let's come to the
legacy of monsters creatures the endos
swarmer these are 2 ft long insectoids
found in kazakistan and individually
they can be also called a super species
due to their radioactive nature and
being bigger than a normal insect but as
a swarm maybe they can be called a sub
Tian as they can Emit and consume
radiation around them the new entries
from Legacy of monsters which redefine
the term Titan are the Iron Dragon and
the Frost varak although smaller than
the skull devil or the Maya squid which
are both just super species these two
the Iron Dragon and the frost varak have
unique powers that affect the
surroundings there are in as it flies
the Iron Dragon is capable of
discharging radioactive ions in the air
which forms Aurora like patterns in the
sky the frost varic can reduce the
temperature within its vicinity by
rapidly inhaling large amounts of air it
can also create a mesmerizing iron
radiation glow when it goes underground
and there are more creatures Crees to be
seen in the series which will be
discussed in another video now let's
move on to the war bats these gigantic
Hollow Earth creatures are fast and
agile Flyers which display an excellent
level of maneuverability despite their
size and relatively small wingspans
although they can fly they cannot
manipulate the atmosphere around them
like Mothra Rodan gidora or chots their
only special ability is their venom
secretion which puts their Titan status
into question maybe they are maybe
they're not
and now next Tiamat monar classifies
Tiamat as having a bioelectrical nature
that can discharge electrical currents
at such extreme temperatures that it
boils the ocean often causing electrical
superstorms so massive that they can be
seen from space she is even confident
enough to fight Godzilla for territory
eventually losing to the Big G she can
even manipulate the water around her to
form moms and water spouts and therefore
having quite a great power and influence
over her surroundings so definitely a
Titan titanis Nika this octopus quit
likee creature is the longest creature
in the monsterverse measuring almost 900
ft long which by size standards would
automatically put her on the Titan list
but it's about power not size so Nika
doesn't have devastating Powers but is
still classified as Destroyer why it's
the most intelligent creature and can
mimic Itself by disguising its radiation
signature which means it does radiate
out a certain form of energy therefore
by the logic of legendary it makes her a
Titan now what about Doug originally
called The Hollow Earth lizard it is
bigger than the skull devil longer than
it and definitely more massive as
evident by its round fat physique but
can it be called a Titan or is it just
another Super species well it is big but
there are no specific powers that it
possesses and it is also seen in Pags
hunting The Rock Critters although a f
favorite by the given criteria duck is
not a Titan even though it is thought to
be related to Godzilla as a distant
cousin
species okay so we have two or three
more amhuluk is an aggressive creature
that is willing to kill others in order
to claim territory and resources he is
able to generate bodies for himself
using biot telekinetic neurotransmitters
so long as his head is intact and there
is enough PL matter for him to create a
new one he has telekinetic powers can
poison entire River and water bodies and
can manipulate plan life for his benefit
which is why he tried to take the Amazon
for himself trying to supplant Behemoth
as the guardian of the region and by
those Powers he is a Titan now chots
this is a massive batlik creature with
demonic horns with limited eyesight
having to resort to echolocation to see
things around it it has a very powerful
Sonic Screech which is both an offensive
and a defensive weapon it doesn't seem
to radiate any kind of energy around it
but it can can attract bio El electrical
storms and perpetuate the storm's energy
as it did with the one that came to
Skull Island and stayed there so by that
power he is a Titan now for the rest all
the creatures of Skull Island including
the rock Critter from the hollow Earth
okay the creatures like the malal claw
the mother long legs the scar buffalos
the magma Turtle the siren Jaws the spor
Mantis or even the larger my squids and
the killer chameleons are just large
meapa they are super species some might
even be called subtitles like the Mya
quid whatever that term now means since
size isn't a determining Factor anyway
that it all those others are not Titans
anymore they are just super species so
we have come to the end of this video
and if you like it then watch this one
as well and if you're more interested in
other movie monsters and creatures
especially for ones from the
monsterverse then check out our Channel
as well we might just have things that
you haven't seen before so like
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
video
till the next time take care fam